[Music]
my name is Bart Ehrman and I'm professor
philosophy at the University of
Groningen in the Netherlands you're
interested in error theory in the
normative judgments how did you come to
become interested in in this kind of
disagreement I guess when I entered
philosophy I was most interested in
political philosophy so I originally
started out as an economics student and
then I moved into political philosophy
and I guess when I did that it really
bothered me that it sort of wasn't clear
to me whether there were any facts of
the matter about what justices say or
what is what rights people have and so
on so even though initially I was
interested in more in political issues I
gradually moved into more foundational
philosophical philosophical issues and
that's how I became interested in in
meta ethics which is the area of
philosophy that asks foundational
questions about ethics and I guess sort
of the holy grail of meta ethics is the
question is morality objective in some
way or is it subjective in some way and
obviously to answer that question you
have to try to be really clear what you
mean when you call something objective
or subjective so a large part of
metaphysics is about those sorts of
issues so when when do we have
objectivity what exactly is required for
objectivity so that was what I was
initially interested in and I guess I
was initially more attracted to another
view in meta ethics which is known as
realism so realism says that there are
actually facts of the matter about
what's right and what's wrong or what
people have reasons to do and so on but
I guess after having been a committed
realist for quite a few years I became
to doubt more and more that we could
actually make sense of this and so
that's how I gradually moved into an
error theory in ethics and so the error
theory is a view that says that moral
judgments so thoughts about what's right
and wrong what people have reason to do
what we should do what our obligations
are and so on
so the error theory says that those
judgments are sort of attempts to
represent the world as being a certain
way so they ascribe properties to things
in the world so they say of things in
the world that they're right or wrong or
obligatory and so on but then the error
theory says well actually those
properties don't actually exist so there
is no such thing as wrongness or
permissibility or obligations and
therefore all moral judgments are false
and then what I did was well I I thought
well actually the arguments for that
sort of theory generalized beyond moral
judgments I now think and they also
apply to what philosophers call other
normative judgments so that means not
just thoughts about what's right and
wrong and what but what's morally
obligatory and so on but also thoughts
about what there's reason to do in
general what there's reason to believe
what's rational and so on so that's how
I came to defend a narrow theory about
all monetary judgments rather than just
moral judgments the other thing I
believe about the error theory is that
we can't actually believe this very
general error theory so that's another
thing I've I've argued for and the
reason for that is that this very
general error theory applies to all
normative judgments so it also applies
to judgments about reasons or belief so
there's very general error theory says
that there's actually no reason to
believe that error theory
so in order to believe that's very
general our theory is have to believe
that there's no reason to believe the
arrow theory and that is something that
I think we can't do so I think we can't
have a belief and at the same time fully
and consciously and explicitly believed
that there's absolutely no reason to
have that belief so I think we can't
believe the arrow theory and what that
means is that the truth of the arrow
theory isn't going to have any effect
whatsoever on how we make moral
decisions so we should make moral
decisions I think in the way we've
always done I don't believe the arrow
theory myself either so I think we
should just you know look at the pros
and cons of the different options
weighed them up and come to a decision
about what what the best thing to do is
or what the right thing to do is but at
the end of the day leave some place for
uncertainty about believing that this is
the right thing to do absolutely but I
think that is something that anybody
should do really so a lot of realists
would also say I think that you should
never be too sure about your moral
opinions and in fact a lot of realists
would say well we are the people who
could really explain why you shouldn't
be too sure about your moral opinions
because there are facts of the matter
out there and so you might get them
wrong so that is something I think that
anybody working in meta attics would
want to preserve that there is room for
uncertainty but then again if like me
you think that the best arguments in
meta ethics seem to show that this error
theory is true maybe that's an
additional reason for some modesty as to
whether you've got things right even
though you don't believe the error
theory you might you might get close to
believing here in theory
so that might be an additional reason to
be a bit modest about whether you've got
things right how does that affect
politics because you were in at first
interested in philosophy right yeah I'm
not sure actually that's something I'm
thinking about right now so so one thing
I'm interested in is whether so there's
this famous philosopher in philosophy
John Rawls who defended a distinctive
form of liberalism which asks citizens
to bracket certain opinions that they
might have about the good life and I
guess one live debate in philosophy is
whether that presupposes a certain kind
of skepticism about good life and maybe
about morality in general and whether
that kind of skepticism then goes on to
undermining the kind of political view
defenders so one thing I'm thinking
about right now is whether maybe this
unbelievable error theory in the tactics
might help us to say something useful in
defense of the kind of liberalism that
rolls to defend but I should say I'm not
at all sure whether that is going to
work because obviously the danger is
always going to be if you defend
anti-realism about something
normative it's very hard to move from
there to some form of liberalism or
tolerance because liberalism or
tolerance are also going to be it's
going to be the claim that we should be
liberals and we should be tolerance and
that's going to be another long tip
plank that will be undermined if you're
if you're anti-realism is is true so
that's a very difficult thing to do
to carry out and I'm not at all sure
that I'm able to do it but that's
something I'm thinking about at the
moment and what what is your research
focusing at the moment well at the
moment so I I've written a book in
defense of the arrow theory and arguing
that we can't believe the theory so one
thing I'm doing right now is responding
to challenges that people have made to
the arguments in the book and also
thinking a bit further about certain
premises and the arguments that I
thought didn't need to be defended but
that I now see do need some additional
defense so that's one thing that I'm
doing
could you give examples of them one
premise is so in the book I assume that
the normative supervenes on the
descriptive in a certain way and what
that means is that there can't be any
changes in the normative status that
actions have to accompany any changes in
their rightness or wrongness and so on
if those changes are not accompanied by
certain more normative changes so for
example if an action that is right if
that action is to become wrong and there
must be some other change in the world
that makes it the case that the action
that used to be right is now is how
wrong so I used to assume that that was
just completely uncontroversial but
there are now philosophers who are
challenging that assumption and very
well I'm not convinced by the challenge
but it's obviously something that I need
to think more about so that's one of the
things I'm not working on and have you
recently changed your mind about an idea
well I guess it would be this miss
supervenience idea I mean the thing is
so it's a technical philosophical notion
but if you spell it out in a non
philosophical intuitive way it just
seems totally obvious right so how can
an action that is right become wrong
without some other change in the world
it can't just be bear a bear changing
like this or enormous so I used to think
that was obvious and as a result of
reading what people have said about this
I've changed my mind and I now think
that that really needs needs defense and
that happens a lot in philosophy so if
you if you try to do philosophy well
then you'll have to pay attention to
what other people are saying and you
have to read their work and it will
happen quite often that maybe you don't
completely change your mind about a
broad topic but you will change your
mind about you know how I'll be
something is whether something needs
defense whether a certain argument works
or doesn't work so that happens quite a
bit and if you were to choose one
classic philosopher that has really
influenced you who would that be
so do you mean like can it be a
reasonably contemporary philosopher oh
yeah right okay so so the the the
philosopher who really made me think
that I wants to be a philosopher myself
was Derek Parfit so he was philosopher
at Oxford he died a few years ago and as
an undergraduate I read his book reasons
and persons and that made a huge
impression on me
not so much for the conclusions that he
reached but for the way he reached those
conclusion so reasons in person is a
really big book but it's full of really
detailed arguments and he's engaging
with every possible objection that there
could be to through the view that he's
defending to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit a I
dot TV for more debates and talks from
the world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas